citizens of the reject Nation Coy
invited me to be his special plus one
for an event to go watch Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part Uno best
get he's ever one of the most
anticipated movies of the like the last
three years or something for both of us
yeah we love this franchise so much I've
been watching the behind the scenes like
I I love this franchise so much so
easily it was like yeah we I'd love to
go we started shooting this at the
theater and when I say started I mean
like we just started we got permission
but then there was a misunderstanding so
that we had to evacuate premises now
we're in the backyard but guys before we
go on tour review we asked one thing you
know uh jump off a motorcycle and land
yourself on the like button quick little
plot synopsis let me think about this so
Ethan on his IMF crew are back into
action on a mission to obtain this other
half of a key they keep reminding you of
that the terrorists and the world
superpowers are also after it because
it'll gain them access to this AI that
could literally control the world so you
know they're racing across the globe
there's a new villain here who is a part
of Ethan Hunt's pass from before he was
in the IMF so it's kind of personal and
David they've gone Rogue again you know
it goes you know it goes and there you
have it that's the plot of Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part one now
definitely got some positives to go into
we talked a little bit during the
credits but there's also some I would
say mixed bag terrain that hopefully we
will know how to communicate without
spoiling very soon so let's just go over
the very obvious positives Cass and
actions cooking off Tom Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise is I don't know how he does it I
don't know how he finds new 11s like you
know the concept of turning it up to 11.
you think every Mission Impossible he's
found the 11 and yet he lives it here
I've always said he's the drama Daniel
Day-Lewis in the action Jackie Chan and
one very intense body this is that as
like a showcase for two and a half hours
the way he does comedy in this I really
enjoyed because it actually brings in
some of his Tropic Thunder miming
sensibilities he's such a good comedic
actor and it's the physicality of him
because he knows how to not only use his
body for drama that is literally not
talking but also comedically and I feel
like this is a big Showcase of his
comedic physical uh language the
Showcase is that with action in a way
that is maybe the funniest action of the
franchise I think the Ghost Protocol is
the funniest writing but I think
comedically this has a lot of that
Jackie Chan prop comedy that I think Tom
Cruise doesn't get enough credit for
while also acting as freaking eyeballs
out the Tom Cruise of it all is is is
amazing there's a reason he's the last
movie star I love I'd love Tom Cruise
yeah yeah I love Tom Cruise very much so
too especially on the big screen we know
he has that passion for the action but
that fervor for the intensity and the
emotion to help sell those action scenes
that much more he gets a chance to go
back to being a little bit more of a
darker Ethan Hunt this time around I
wouldn't say as dark as he gets in like
Mission Impossible 3 but also showcase
some of the more comedic side but
there's other cast members here who are
also great who really deserve to be
talked about Haley Atwell I don't know
if it's really a spoiler or not uh not
really because it's the first thing you
ever learn about this person she's the
thief I'll just keep it at that she's a
professional Thief which is very
different from a professional spy it's
refreshing breath of fresh favorite new
character since Renner she is the
absolute standout in this movie it's so
good she works well with anyone she's
bouncing off of she fits perfectly into
this world her chemistry with Tom Cruise
she's Tom Cruise movies she's great like
this is a star to match Tom Cruise's
charismatic star capabilities by far and
before we go into some action scenes I
think another one who dude the surprise
of the movie for me can I please hop
Clemente five for years it's actually
pronounced clementia oh excuse me I had
to learn that to make sure I interviewed
her when I talked to her and I was like
missed on the teeth Palm is a force in
this I'm always struck by how passionate
she is how intense she is and how like
joyous and bubbly she is but in an
intense way that isn't cloying it's a
really hard line to walk to be like that
much of an energy believe me I know I'm
a lot the way they use the energy of
palm in this is so different than mantis
it's so different than you've ever seen
and she's terrified she's got the thing
that I think a lot of action movies try
to do or they do the Silent Assassin
she's just quiet she's not silent they
do it I think the best I've ever seen in
modern Cinema so impressed with her she
is like a sledgehammer what I think they
did better here with her is what I
wanted out of what they did like I enjoy
Henry cavill's presence in Fallout but
they set him up in Fallout as like he's
the guy who's sitting to get the job
done he doesn't play by anybody he's
really he gets his ass kicked a lot in
that movie
it doesn't really seem like the guy you
send in to get the job a lot of the time
she is she is that thing that I wanted
Henry Cavill to be that they kept saying
Henry Cavill would be she's not really
given like a crap ton of lines but you
could tell she's having fun with this
role and especially as so many of us
know her as mantis this is the
antithesis but also it's like so
maniacal and gleeful I loved her
presence here I thought she was great
the rest of the cast as we know you know
generally pretty great you know Rebecca
Ferguson Ferguson she's not in it that
much but when she's there it's effective
literally shows up on screen and you're
just like oh I remember what happiness
is heartfelt sincere Luther vandro like
the rest of the cast's really good now
the action scenes this is like the main
thing people show up for right there are
some stupendous action scenes in here I
would I would absolutely say the one
that you see teasing the trailer a lot
of the time where it's Tom Cruise and
Haley Atwell who are like handcuffed
while inside of a car I would say my
favorite action scene of the movie Coy
was talking a lot about the comedy that
can be infused in some of the action
here I really thought they had a great
bounce that like that was a scene that
was truly exciting intense also was
making the theater laugh a lot yeah
because intentionally though like they
had things in there and the other thing
too they go through a lot of the same
locations that they go through in the
car chase scene and the bomb and fast
hex like literally some of the exact
same spots and it was cool to watch it
here because you're like but this is
real like these are locked off shots you
can tell there's none of the CGI stuff
happening here because that's the
mission impossible the franchise Thrive
so much on so it's cool to get this
comparison and it felt that much more
vital and real because we just saw one
that had used a lot of crazy fantasy
action it literally like a one-to-one
ring old style movie making new style
movie yeah and it's beautiful to see how
they do yeah it's Carnage this feels
like when you're a kid and you go see a
blockbuster and I feel like that's now
been made into a negative people are
saying that derogatory they're like oh
it's a blockbuster when we used to say
that it meant a good thing and I'm using
it that way it feels like going to the
movies and having yourself some popcorn
but not in a way that dumbs down the
experience it's just so joyous there's
some stuff if I have a bit of a mixed
opinion on I don't know someone else who
sought a different screening and they
said their crowd was losing their
on the part where the one they've been
promoting a lot where he jumps off the
cliff with the motorcycle free Falls I
had a different experience here where I
was I was let down by the overall scene
because the stunt in and of itself is so
goddamn dangerous and so impressive yet
in terms of it being a scene I feel like
there's no reason not a lot of early
reactions have actually been
highlighting this moment because more
than a lot of the other stunts in this
franchise it really felt like Tom Cruise
he wanted to do a stunt and he got to do
the stunt and the stun in and of itself
is cool and but normally the build up to
the stunt is tense then the stun scene
itself is super intense but here the
build up is tense but the actual stunt
while still cool surprisingly doesn't
feel as impactful of a scene I think my
issue was in the edit because I was
invested in the stunt and I was invested
in the other plot that was happening but
I think the choice to leave the stunt
when they did to go to the other plot
and then come back under your mind both
of them because yes they're tonally so
different you were like I want to know
more about I guess I want to stay here
do I stay here yeah the momentous build
up to the sun kind of felt like it kept
getting interrupted instead of ramping
up excitement to it it makes you not
enjoy the juxtaposition as opposed to
being like I'm fraught with Peril you're
like wait now I'm undermined the other
part of it is because this is an insane
thing that they did if you watch the
behind the scenes of it it is a gnarly
thing and it's the reason why they've
been promoting this stuff it's easily
the craziest stunt of this is It's the
stunt of the movie The issue is is that
that stunt in it of itself makes for
just a short-lived moment and not a full
scene if you think about like even him
going underwater even though there's a
CGI enhancements that seems like a few
minutes hanging on the plane that's a
full scene I'm in the burst it's a full
scene so even if you see the behind the
scenes you still get the drama of that
scene and here it's like he's off the
cliff
exactly as long as it is in the trailer
and now and that does change the
intensity because you're like wait I've
seen this but I know some people who
were who started I want to see it with a
crowd that has that reaction we saw it
with a full crowd and no one reacted to
it but I wanna I wonder if we would
react differently with a crowd
definitely definitely cheering and then
the other big one that's been teased a
lot and this is the one I see people
constantly talking about social media is
the train sequence now here's where I
feel like I'll have the most unpopular
opinion it would be such a spoiler for
me to tell you what this train sequence
entails the best I can say without spoil
is it kind of reminds me of of a part of
Uncharted 2 I would say this train seems
a loving concept I could tell a lot of
the crowd was on the edge of their seat
the thing that was kind of pulling me on
here's where I'm gonna sound like a
total I know it's just a fact of
the matter is that preceding this moment
there was already some stuff on top of
the train that was super CGI the thing
is this the mission impossible franchise
has been so well revered for they don't
do CGI and if they do it's only to help
hide some stuff but not such a thing
that will overshadow a moment I found
moments being very much overshadowed by
that and in this particular train seeing
us a lot of people are really much
crowding I love the concept of it
obviously the whole thing with like the
performers are not CGI you can tell the
performers are really doing stuff but a
lot of their surrounding Landscapes I
still felt like they were encapsulated
and ultimately what was a green screen
and maybe I'm wrong but it certainly
looked that way and I think that's the
difference and that's what would make me
not feel the danger to the sequence this
is a weird thing to be like I wish they
were really doing this and that makes
your life more because I'm so used to
Mission Impossible doing that because
I'm so used to this franchise doing that
it distracted me that much more so I
wasn't able to get as immersed into the
suspense like obviously these guys will
be fine by that we've seen every Tom
Cruise stunt and you've seen promoting
the movie so we know they're gonna be
fine in the end these actors but the
idea is to be so immersed into the
moment that you forget about that and I
hear I never forgot about it and when
you said that in the credits we were
talking about that scene I immediately
was like oh you're right and I
acknowledged it and in hindsight I can
take myself out and I was like oh that
would have removed me but since to me I
was so focused narratively on some of
those elements it didn't pull me out
until he said it and then I was like so
I think you'll have one or two
experiences I didn't say it while you
were watching he was like hey do you
know who said oh full moon how to ruin
this moment loudly over the thing no but
like when he mentioned in the credits I
was like oh you're right but I in in
hindsight I can acknowledge that so I
think you viewer will either have the
experience where you're so in you can
acknowledge it after or you uh you'll
have like Greg's experience where you're
like man we're in this and I do want to
say while we're talking about stunts in
this franchise this is an action
franchise that I would put above 90 of
action franchises It's tricky because
this mixed bag stuff we're on now is
because it's not over 90 of the mission
impossible stunts in action it's grading
on a bell curve Mission Impossible is so
far above everything else that we're
saying this in compared to itself but
it's still better than 90 of action
movies ever made so I would say like
this is around the middle of my Mi
experience but that's still in my top
five percent of action movies okay this
is there's seven movies right yeah I
would easily place because here's the
thing guys I love absolutely love three
through six so four films I love right
three four five six seven three
I I love three through six this one I
liked and I feel like I'll like it even
more in a second viewing here's the
thing and maybe this is why I wasn't as
wrapped up in the narrative so to speak
like you were saying with that train
sequence which is this movie's two hours
and 43 minutes there's a lot on on paper
that I appreciate about what they're
going for and when the two hour 43
minute run time most of it is not action
it shouldn't be action I'm not saying
that's the problem the parts where I
would say is it's not all negative and
you know if I have a super negative
about it I would not watch my words I
would tell you guys if I was just like
oh my God I hate this or I was bored it
was such a fluctuating mixed bag for me
with most of the movie in terms of
everything that surrounded the action
scenes that would lead into the action
scenes that sometimes it would actually
take away some of the excitement and
pulse pounding nature of the action
because I wasn't enjoying the stuff that
was in action as much I mean there are
elements where it seems like they're
aiming to capture that specific dark
Espionage tone from the first mission
impossible movie which I do appreciate
the best way I could say it is this is
in the most simplistic terms is like it
has all the ingredients of all the other
things I loved and all the other Mission
Apostle movies for the things that were
not action I mean Christopher McCrory
wrote and directed this movie and he
wrote and directed the last two that I
absolutely love the recipe that was
ultimately cooked up okay I get that
they're going for something that's a
little bit more topical to today
sometimes the commentary feels like way
too heavy-handed I feel like someone is
talking ideas at me and not really
living so much in the moment not all the
time but a good amount of time a lot of
the time it feels like they're going for
something that is darker but it doesn't
resonate as menacing or intense it can
just resonate as dramatic dour so it
loses a little bit of life not all the
time but a good amount of the time it
can feel that way maybe it only stood
out to me this time on my first go
around and maybe I won't have it as much
of my Takeaway on a second go around but
on my first go around it would
definitely impact the way I would
ultimately feel about sometimes when we
get to an action figure sometimes I have
to feel like I'm relieved we're at an
action scene right now as opposed to
attention as opposed to like we built up
to here yeah which is like the other
movies did it so well I know some people
will come at me and be like we're just
taking out some merits this is number
seven and this is clearly a movie that
is not Standalone also we're fighting
over which one is like the yeah or
fourth best in a film of seven like
that's how good these movies are we're
like what's the fourth fifth best of a
seven like they're all that good but if
you want honest opinion like I I have
some similar qualms with uh the movie's
got an AI element that is the plot I
felt that at times I was impressed that
20 years ago when the first one came out
the plot itself would be a Sci-Fi this
would be like oh my God Blade Runner now
it's present now it's a topical like you
said and sometimes I was like man they
trust the audience they're letting us
just have this they're spoon feeding us
and then other times it's like here's a
shovel of data and I was like you just
trusted us so much so much Exposition so
many cases the way they go over the key
I made it think about the key the key
thing in the plot when I was talking
about the plot because they kind of
treat the audience like they're an idiot
in the first and then sometimes they
don't and I'm like where's this writing
so I would say that while we're judging
the action also in the script element
there are times that it's that clever
Mission Impossible highbrow intellectual
action film and other times where it's
like oh we're releasing a movie against
other things we got to make sure
everyone gets it and I've never felt in
that mission possible I've never felt
they were like let's just just take it
down and I'm like don't do that to me
trust me this is seven how I'm imagining
someone hearing what we're saying is
going like but I feel like the other
movies kind of did that I'm like yeah
they they do they just do it better it's
like you're baking this is also two
hours and 40 minutes so this also
gestates a lot longer to keep with that
the souffle sometimes too hot sometimes
not hot enough exactly false and
sometimes it burns it really needed a
kind of a punch-up it was the first time
and I know that they they must do these
for the other ones this was the first
time I really felt like they came up
with action scenes first and then they
thought of plots to to work their way to
them a lot of the time and I and this is
the first time I was distracted by that
there's clearly other moments like that
in the other movies but here I felt that
a little bit more and then they have
this other villain here Isaiah Morales I
think is the same yeah they do have
something in here with him that is an
attempt to make it a more personal
villain for Ethan Lincoln to his past
but it honestly feels like some stuff
they made up just for this movie not
like it's always been a part of the
character so it doesn't really land that
strong he's a Charming actor but after
the villain that we got in the last
couple I'm like
I don't know it's like it's kind of the
problem I have with the way a lot of
these characters are written this time
around everyone is just given like like
you said data everyone's just given
explained everyone's given
exposition to the point where I never
felt that yeah we're like of course
these movies have Exposition this is the
thing it's like when you say stuff
you're like the other movies do it yeah
we see you coming the way this movie
does it is I feel like a lot of time I
was listening to ideas in an outline
less than I was listening to characters
yeah yeah and also there's some style
choices that make it more severe I think
you and I talked about the like 180 rule
a couple times that's super dirty film
stuff but there are times where it shot
distractingly avant-garde and like it it
causes a certain like paranoia and Noir
but sometimes it doesn't fit the tone or
it does like this break of the 180 rule
where you're like I feel like I'm
watching the BBC behind the scenes of
the scene and I'm like wait we were just
with this character why are we over here
in this room I think meant to be
disorienting but it's disorienting in a
way that's like it feels messy and not a
a style Choice yeah it just felt messy
to me I feel like we got so caught up in
trying to communicate that it was just a
mixed bag and that we're not negative
like watch this on the big screen
because it's so certainly worth it and I
am definitely excited I can't wait to
get this movie yeah I can't see it
that's the thing it's like Indiana Jones
I canceled all things I had to watch it
again I was like no I don't care to
watch it again this one I have tickets
to go watch it again and I'm like I'm
looking forward I'm still looking
forward to it I think we were positive
for 10 minutes and then negative for two
but we're so in love with the movie that
it's like man those two felt bad like
the act of saying bad things about
something you've enjoyed is hard so like
I enjoyed a lot so it's still like a
mission impossible movie it's still one
of the best action movies ever made it's
just uh we're trying to be honest I am
considering the fact that like no the
main things you show up for really more
than deliver so I would still give it an
8 out of ten just due to that fact you
know what I mean but overall for me like
my personal feeling on a first go around
I would say it's 7.5 I'm between 7.5 and
8.5 and my overall just feelings I would
say say for a mission impossible it's a
7.5 for an action movie it's a nine so
it lands that anymore better yeah like
that's so that's where it is it's just
there's two scales there's the mission
impossible scale there's the action
movie scale and it's high in the action
movie scale and good on a mission
impossible scale it would be easier to
talk about this movie if people were
just plain and simple like just purely
negative then I could just like be super
blunt but I'm like but I don't want
people to think I'm going to see it it's
one of those where I get so caught up in
my head and now I'm just talking way too
much yep for 20 minutes all right guys
well Mission Impossible movie leave your
thoughts down below
I gotta get to
cut her this oh my God
this what you have out here on YouTube
it is nowhere near as long as coin I
have this is a benefit when you're at a
theater is it forces you to be honest we
should have let him check us out sooner
[Music]